si tu perds tu perds 1200 ou la vache à
lait 2 par contre si tu gagnes l'auto
remboursera les 600 euros que perdu dans
la sébile au [ __ ] l'accord est retombé
à moncheaux attention c'est parti ce que
tu veux mais qu est ce qu il va vous
montrer son talent hagard loser loser
est très fort mentalement
red bull au football ou le matelot dit
lors du la syrie au centre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est bon
avant magnifique car souvent ces femmes
là mais c'est stanley comme ça c'est
devenu stade nous les micros
par contre toi c'est devenu cet accord
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le score il ya vingt-huit chérie tu
transpires na waie la brocante est
ouverte
et toi tu as la militante à john et tout
y est à 12h15
l'arrêté ne nous écoute pas
[Applaudissements]
les guerres lusa du cast away casta sa
taille et boucherit ombre merci
christine j'adore kelly christien
calibration mais qu'à une baisse à
paillettes
benji perte un coup de troubles les
écoutes 21 janvier
[Applaudissements]
on ne sait rien que ces personnes
jalouses et ses personnels
c'est lucas le trophée du grand centre
toi recul des ventes albums et a pas le
mental d'un match en cinq points
[Applaudissements]
dans trop belle que si tu perds mais
c'est bon je le sais c'est mon toit
tu as et que c'est quoi ton problème à
ses origines écoute pas on n'écoute pas
les coûts d'occupation
je suis président et hybrides alors je
vais avoue lui disais tout mais pas plus
étroites et aux conneries quand même on
croit en toi mais offrant doivent être
arrêtés
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est la malchance alors est-ce que vous
avez quelque chose à dire à votre
demeure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir au delà de voir que castaldi les
manades tocard
[Applaudissements]
chez vous est ce que vous voulez voir
des gens qui font de la peine est un
plan sur cette partie
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
dire à bâtir le dur belime benjamin ou
bien contre vote contre l'autre adaptera
sa main ne concentre pas sur la personne
en face de toi on s'en fout de lui ces
personnes disent rien serait ou alou
c'est une merde
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à lever jusqu'à compte est halal
droit benjamin mental
benjamin est en passe de gagner je le
sens en fait tentative est née sur des
colis oui il a dit des conneries tout a
foiré avec votre smartphone alors
benjamin franchement c'est pas très bien
barré non mais par contre c'est parce
que tu vas gagner que je veux devenir
une légende que ce tony n'a pas de
corones tu peux y aller par amour madame
à se défoncer et tu vas y arriver
comment c'est venu en ami je veux faire
quelque chose que je ne fais jamais tu
veux jouer avec l'iphone non marie jo
smartphones
oui bien sûr on l'humilie et pour
l'humilier joue avec une pièce de deux
euros sert à acheter
mais benjamin au web et de vous
affronter bath causé que des péniches
art j'adorais le mont pinçon charlot
salir des années arrive
[Applaudissements]
chérie
cyril jour comme tu fais l'amour et ça
ira parfaitement way
[Applaudissements]